I'm back from Atlantic city. I shot some of army of the dead in Atlantic city.
I couldn't wait to get out of Albuquerque and get to Atlantic city.
Couldn't believe I was saying I can't wait to get to Atlantic city,
got to Atlantic city,
Atlantic city and was super depressed because Atlantic city super depressed,
all good. Uh, stayed at a hotel that lost their gaming license.
So there's no casino in the hotel that we were staying in.
Yeah.
So I'm done with that. I'm done with army of the dead.
I got one more shoosh day I have to do in Albuquerque.
So it's all good going to drama. No's out real good and plenty.
When I get there,
I'm going to get there and now my lips just go like this and break and bleed and
all good. Uh, and when you go to the bathroom, literally,
it's very painful, so it's not good. So, um.
Uh.
W I got back from, uh, Atlantic city. Atlantic city is crazy, man.
I'm doing a zombie movie. Okay.
So I'm dealing with like a bunch of zombies when I'm, I'm on, on set,
just going for some reason,
that's the zombie noise for all of the zombie shows and, uh,
for walking dead, you know, I, you not do it.
I walk outside on the boardwalk in Atlantic city and I see this homeless guy and
for real, he's going like that. And I was like, Oh,
zombies in real life. Um, but yeah, dude,
it's crazy. Uh, about the, about Atlantic city and how it's a thing,
rooms are like $50 a night.
Yeah.
So, um, yeah. And, uh, but it was cool to,
to be in Atlantic city for extended period of time, I guess. I mean, I was in,
I've only played like the Brugada and Harris and I go the day of,
and I leave the next day because why would I stay in Atlantic city about dude
when you're in the Borgata? And when you're in the, um,
like there's an old hotel called ocean, there's a few hotels. When you go in,
you might as well be in Vegas, do it, except for the people look like.
Freeze.
They're just not as good looking as the people in Vegas now,
Vegas has the troglodytes and the make no mistake.
If they're slot machines around, there's troglodytes around. Now,
if you were my opener, you'd say what's a troglodyte. Well,
troglodyte is somebody is a troll.
It's basically a troll that lives under a bridge or something like that. Anyway,
it's a dumb word. You know what I mean? Troglodyte, like, just make it shorter,
call it a truck or a troll,
but they don't the English language likes to get jiggy with it.
So then they're going to get treated with it, dude.
I'm I'm wearing my future's so bright way too bright shirt,
because my future's way too bright got me with the shades on over here.
And you could see the back if you were behind me, but you can't right now.
It's all good. I'm not going to show it to you cause I'm, don't want to.
And that's respect, dude. That's straight up respect. I mean,
not doing what I wanted me doing exactly what I want to do for you guys.
You're welcome.
Anyway, dude, I am back.
And I was in every, uh, Friday. I went,
I went to New York city because it was a,
because I didn't want to be in Atlantic city for like two days off because I
would have, you know,
it's crazy weird to be here, like on a, in a casino,
but also near the beach S a Jersey
and a seagulls. Even the seagulls are like, what the is going on around here?
Why are there casinos, squawk? And so, uh,
like you see them, if you look close to their face or like squawk,
why are there troglodytes? Skok um,
squawk. This was ours a little while ago. Squawk did squawk.
Um, so I went to New York city. Yeah.
And every time you go to New York, you see the most new year.
It's all unreal. It's just unreal.
I was in New York and I saw two dudes straight
up fighting with each other, arguing,
like not physically fighting, but they were like, it was like,
the next step was the guy.
One of the guys has to like duck. Cause the other guy is going to punch.
And they were arguing with,
to each other about arguing with each other about, uh,
whose team was better Jersey, Sidney Ark.
They were talking about the giants and the jets. It was like, you're, he's like,
your team. You ain't. Your teammate. But like for real angry.
Um, and they were like, you piece of. You ain't. He was like, you ain't.
Your teammates. And you ain't. He was like, he was like,
and the other guy was like, I'm gangster. And he was like, Oh,
you ain't gangster. You ain't without your boys. Like, that's what was going on.
And they kept on like walking away, but then walking close to each other.
Now this was the most New York. Not yet, but this was the most New York.
They were doing that to each other. And I, you not, dude.
They were actually for real angry with each other,
but they were also dapping each other. And high-fiving each other.
Your friends are not, I am not boosting you dude.
They were like, you, you ain't without your boys, you ain't gangster.
I am gay some other, I'll kill you. And they were like, Hey, your.
But I respect that. But you. But they literally said they respect that,
but we're doing that. And they were yelling at the top of their lens lungs.
Everybody was watching and they were going to shoot each other,
but they were dabbing.
Why were they doing it? Don't know.
But that's the New York way in a New York minute.
Ooh, everything can change in the New York minute. Uh,
my mom, when I was younger would do, would say New York minute. And,
but she would do it, not the singing way. She would be like, Hey,
in a New York minute, in a New York minute.
And it would always make me mad because the New York minute is 60 seconds.
And that's how much regular men it is.
But she thought she was crafty and cool and poetic. Now that's what she does.
And it's all good. My babies moms are dramatic. If your mom made dramatic,
guess what? She's your dad.
Because moms are dramatic as women get older.
And especially if they pop kids out, when they become a mom, they get dramatic.
When my mom saw Columbine, she dropped. When she saw Columbine on, on the news,
she dropped her notebook, who the drops stuff in real life. For real who,
who for real goes, uh, and then drop something,
pull your Kaiser San Jose at the end, she dropped her notebook on my foot.
I go out mom, what the? And she says, Oh, shut the up.
Dude.
This, she said, shut the up. You know, a mom. Oh, shut the up. [inaudible]
um, so yeah, so in a New York minutes,
you dropped the notebook on my foot and it's all good.
Now can I get the cowlick down on the back of my head now? And it's all good.
Does it me off? Yeah, this is going to change it. No, it doesn't matter,
but I need to look good. No, it doesn't matter. But, um,
so anyway, I did that. I, she did,
she dropped the notebook and that was when I real,
that was when I came up with the thing where I was like, wow, dude,
moms are dramatic, but dads aren't, you know,
dads aren't, that's just laugh it off.
And.
I don't know, man.
They get maybe my, my, my dad's sentimentalist too, though.
My dad will look at it. Like it's just,
and that's probably why I'm sentimental, man.
Like when I see like involving like a D a kid and an a and a
dad, if it's, I don't give a. If it's a, it could be a Trivago commercial.
I'm crying immediately. If he goes, like,
I go to Trivago to get all my hotel deals because I,
because when I'm staying with my son, we need and I'm just it.
That guy from Travago the commercial that guy's so handsome, you know,
for sure he's got no kids because he just stays
the Trivago guys. The. When I went out, when I get older,
I want to be the Trivago guy. No, I don't want to actually work for Trivago,
but I want to be that like, that guy is so, so handsome. It's hilarious.
If you have all even gray hair, you're the. Unless it's white,
then you don't look good. And that's the rules and I don't make the rules, dude.
The rules are the rules and I figured them out.
Um, anyway, um, but that's yeah,
so I saw that New York thing and it was insane.